the sims allows you to simulate
life and customize my new details of
your characters and their homes but you
may not know about the stranger weirder
lore that lies beneath the surface of
the long beloved series
the biggest mystery involves one of the
most well-known sims
ever bella goth
[Music]
i know i'm not the only one with
nostalgic memories of making bizarre
families and create a sim as a kid
but many of the pre-made sims have
detailed personalities
interests relationships and mysteries
long time players might recognize some
of these characters and family names
like land grab
newbie and bachelor but i guarantee the
conspiracies and connections between
them run deeper than you know
bella goth has appeared in her iconic
red dress in just about every sims game
in the sims 1 the elegant and athletic
bella lives with her husband mortimer
and her daughter cassandra at five sim
lane
she enjoys reading chess golf and
mourning over tombstones
but in the summer of 2004 shortly before
the sims 2
bella goes missing the in-game story
never
explicitly states what happened to her
but fragments of evidence might just
allow us to piece the mystery
together if your sim uses a fingerprint
scanner on the furniture in the goth
family's house
you'll find that most of the furniture
was recently touched by bella meaning
she hasn't been gone for too long
the weirdest part is bella does
technically exist
in the game but she's hidden within the
game code and can only be found using
cheats or third-party programs
this version of her has no personality
points career
memories or aspirations on the goth
family tree panel bella's portrait is in
color not in black and white which
implies that the game doesn't consider
her to be deceased
while the goth family in pleasant view
mourns bella's disappearance
drinking milk from cartons that bear her
missing person notice
she inexplicably appears by herself in
the mysterious desert community of
strange town
except things aren't quite right with
her she has no memories of her family or
her past
a different voice and a slightly
different appearance and personality
than the bella hidden within pleasant
view
she can also be befriended and married
poor mortimer thinks his wife is missing
when she's really just out in the desert
partying to katy perry
but it's a proven nope it turns out that
bella was last seen denying advances
from
don lothario her daughter's promiscuous
fiance on his patio
the last thing she did before vanishing
to strange town was look into dawn's
telescope
if you've played the sims you may
already know that telescopes are the
most sure-fire way to be abducted by
aliens
aliens and alien abductions are
long-established aspects of the sims
series
in different games you can visit other
planets make an alien a part of your
family
and even have alien children
extraterrestrials have attempted to
overthrow simnation multiple times and
are able to completely disguise their
appearance and voices to perfectly blend
in with humans
so you can never truly know who's real
and who might just be an
alien in disguise in fact strange town
is home to many anomalies and peculiar
citizens including quite a few aliens
strange town is an odd place littered
with secret labs a nuclear power plant
and a cult that worships a cow demon
named beelzebeef
but the most notable landmark in the
town is a ufo sitting broken down
in a crater where it crashed the ufo
could belong to one of the town's alien
residents
like pollination tech number nine smith
an alien man who quote
really thinks his human disguise is
working hmm
it's said in game that the crashed ufo
came to deliver
a personal item to pt9 smith who knows
what that could imply
but if that was the ufo that abducted
bella goth
then maybe she was the delivery although
mortimer and cassandra have memories of
seeing bella be abducted by aliens it's
unexplained what exactly happened to her
up there
her lost memories are usually chalked up
to alien experiments wiping her mind but
due to the inexplicable differences
between her pleasant view and strange
town selves
some suspect strange town bella is
actually a clone or an alien
impersonating her but developer maxis
insists that the two distinct bellas are
the same person
in terms of the game's storyline they
even published a written interview with
bella on the sims 2 website that
explains her disappearance
denies the existence of a clone and
mentions faint memories of
green men with black eyes maybe she does
just have amnesia but
then again if she was a clone that's
probably just what the aliens would want
us to think
in the online interview with bella she
says that she's tried to go home to
mortimer cassie and alex but
she says there's something strange about
this town every time i try to leave
i end up back here in the sims 3 which
takes place earliest
in the series timeline bella is a child
growing up in sunset valley just down
the road from her childhood friend and
future husband mortimer
however it's assumed the sims 3 follows
multiple alternate timelines because
while bella is still a kid
her gravestone exists at the same time
on a neighboring
planet producer sarah holding confirmed
bella goth's headstone in the lunar
lakes graveyard belongs to the same
bella from the sims 2.
but lunar lakes bella has a completely
different appearance with yellow hair
greenish skin
and a grim face apparently she simply
died of old age
meaning we know that she didn't die from
drowning in a pool without a ladder or
from being stuck behind an
impassable obstacle like poorly placed
furniture
it's unknown how or when bella got to
lunar lakes or if she ever even reunited
with her family after her abduction
but it seems possible that she may have
been abducted again or that she set out
for the stars in search of her abductors
maybe by using strange town's ufo sims 4
sadly abandons many of these previous
story lines while still including
alternate universe versions of many
characters including bella goth as a
young adult as well as the very first
pre-made sims
bob and betty newby who appear as bob
and eliza pancakes
however an expansion pack for the sims 4
features the desert town strangerville
which clearly references strange town
and its alien residence
featuring conspiracy theorists a
mysterious crater
in the roswell family which references
the 1947
roswell new mexico ufo incident even if
the lore behind bella goth runs thin
in the newer games fun references and
supernatural easter eggs are
ever present as you might expect there
are countless fan theories speculating
further what happened to bella goth
since the details don't quite add up
one theory involves the caliente sisters
who were both romantically involved with
don lothario and who moved into
pleasantview the night before bella
disappeared
just after bella was abducted by aliens
her wealthy husband mortimer began
dating dina caliente this might sound
like a reality show love triangle so far
but might i add that the caliente
sisters are part
alien some think that because of this it
could be possible that after bella
rejected don lothario he was worried
she'd rat him out to her daughter and
his fiance cassandra
so he called up the caliente sisters to
use their alien family connections to
wipe bella's memory
and while dina was there she used the
opportunity to take bella out of the
picture and move in on mortimer and his
money
but of course that's all just
speculation and forum theories
whether you play the sims to make your
own characters decorate eclectic
mansions or achieve your sims career
aspirations
even if that aspiration is eating
grilled cheese every day
it's undeniable that the sims lore has
some strange stories
and a colorful cast of characters we
might never know what exactly bella saw
when she looked through that telescope
but with countless easter eggs hidden
imagery and
iterations of bella throughout dozens of
games she is
undoubtedly one of the most recognizable
enigmatic sims in the series
hopefully her story continues going
forward the truth has to be out there
[Music]
you